foreign
T is with us Brett is in Charleston
South Carolina hi Brett welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi thank you both for having me on it's
a pleasure to talk to you sure what's up
so I grew up uh very poor you know often
not even having meal and then as my uh
grew into a senior in high school both
my parents got jobs making six figures
and it seemed like it was so fun eating
out and just living recklessly as a
whole family and then my parents got
divorced everything just kind of fell
apart and I now have been blessed of
owning my own business and making a
pretty considerable salary increase and
I'm finding myself feeling fearful about
the money that I'm making I know I still
have eleven thousand dollars to pay off
on uh baby step two
but I just am kind of afraid of the
effect of money I I just I'm living in
fear and I'm hoping to get them help be
more specific what is it you're afraid
of
you know I just I don't want the
lifestyle of money to be able to tear
away the things that really matter to me
um you know I don't want it so that
we're just eating out and living you
know like this great life and then some
of the family values kind of go by the
wayside how do you find those values
while earning greater money you know how
do you stay rooted I guess
okay
um
number one I don't think you're gonna
have a problem because you are watching
for it
it's the people that don't watch for it
that um that it gets so you're not
looking to money
to be your salvation
and so it's not going to let you down
people that get in trouble are the ones
that say oh I'll be happy when
and then they're not happy when okay
because money's you know success money
anything's a bully in the schoolyard as
soon as you achieve it and you step
across you know he draws a Line in the
Sand and says if you step across this
line I'm going to punch you and you step
across the line he backs up and draws
another line and says if you step across
this line then I'm really going to punch
you you know and that's what it it's
always moving this I'll be happy when
I'll be happy when I'll be happy when
and those are the people that getting
money gets them off track because they
thought money had a power to do things
it does not have it does not have the
power to give you happiness it does not
have the power to give you Joy it does
not have the power to give you peace it
does not have the power to
uh create values in your family unless
you try to give it that power and then
it will let you down
but you're not going to do that so I'm
really not worried about you
I appreciate you saying that you know
and just a dad of four daughters I just
want to make sure I you know use it to
its best opportunity so like my little
boy you know we finally got a decent car
after we're gonna bankrupt and uh my
little boy at the time
um is a little guy he's the smallest of
the Ramses right and uh we take we get
them and finally get a car that's not
got like a dent in it you know I mean it
finally get a decent vehicle and he's in
the back seat and we're doing the old
family drive around the block in the new
car everybody check out the new car oh
we're excited right you know the routine
right and he leans back and he goes
we're doing pretty good
right and see that's a signal that
there's a problem
and so I just stopped the car and I said
we aren't doing good at all I'm doing
good you got nothing
I'm doing pretty good you you're broke
okay and so you just need to know that's
where you're starting from b-r-o-k-e
Buddy and so um you know and and so
that's in other words we did not allow
money to be the value
of okay now we're okay when we get this
better car oh now we're okay if we get
to move in that house oh now we're okay
if I have a thing a label on my purse or
whatever the crap it is right and so you
know you're just not gonna allow your
family to be defined by this and so
money then become oh PT Barnum had a
wonderful saying he said money is a
fabulous slave it's a horrible Master
yeah and that's what we're talking about
is who's in charge here you are the
money you're in charge the money's not
so you're not going to fall prey to
these things as long as you keep money
not don't let money be in charge in
anyone's life that is in your purview
your you know your spouse your kids as
for me and my house money is a tool
um it's not the master you see what I'm
doing
yeah yeah I just would I would say this
Brett I could feel the fear on you and
that's why we push you to be specific
and I think you're afraid that more
money and a fluency that comes with that
is going to distract you and tempt you
to do things you don't want to do as
opposed to say no the money I make and
any wealth that comes with that is going
to allow me to do more of what I believe
we should do so I think it's boundaries
setting up those boundaries like Dave
said when do you hear something or see
something or smell something among the
family where it goes that's not right I
want to nip that in the butt and I think
it's setting boundaries and not worrying
about the Temptation if you've got clear
boundaries uh I think you're going to do
more of the right things instead of
doing things that you don't want to do
but you you grew up hearing and most of
us did
uh that that you know rich people are
evil or they're all Crooks or something
like that which is absolute hogwash
it's absolutely it's an absolute it's
asinine it's an absolute lie but it's
the stuff that poor people or hopeless
people say because they're jealous here
and and so you know most rich people I
know are no more crooked than the poor
people I know
and they're no more righteous than the
poor people I know you know the amount
of money you have doesn't make you a
crook or righteous
uh it's a character quality so you know
it's a moral money's a morally does not
have morals it just attaches itself to
people who do
um and so yeah you just you got this
message from childhood from the old from
the from the growing up Hood the
neighborhood and you're like you know oh
well I'm afraid I'm gonna become one of
those evil rich people and uh then you
discover no I'm just gonna be one of the
good rich people okay good yeah well I
got it I love what you said about the
Daniel story it's one of my favorite
stories reminds me of something
Shaquille O'Neal said I believe he's
doing his Hall of Fame speech but it's
perspective he said to his kids we ain't
Rich I'm rich exactly so same thing you
know it's like give the kids context
yeah why do I make this money what had
to happen for us to get to this place
now what do we believe we should do with
money and you give it perspective you
know and then the kids and everybody
else goes okay I get it
but you know here's the thing and and
you show the kids it came from hard work
you show the kids the business is
successful because we're helping a lot
of people that's exactly right and hey
oh I had to struggle you know I tell my
kids all the time like I try to remind
they were little when I first started
after this whole broadcasting thing I
remind them all the time how bad the
first broadcasting things I did were
like they don't even deserve to be drug
out of the ditch the ash heap of History
like you had to do bad stuff you had to
do humble stuff you had to struggle uh
it took time to build like this doesn't
just you don't just show up and do the
things I'm doing today and and my all my
kids understand that you know and by the
way they also understand that if they
want more money they've got to go to
work yeah I don't just keep filling up
their bank account
does not destroy your family values no
he brought up eating out several times
eating out does not yeah I think he was
worried about getting away from the
dinner table which I get that then then
I'll make the dinner table a part of the
family tradition part of our part of our
weekly schedule that is uh three nights
a week five nights a week whatever it is
we are all gathering at the table and uh
no you can't book anything across that
and I don't care what your friends are
doing and this is what we do the other
nights we can go out to eat or you go
out with your buddies or do whatever you
can go to somebody else's house whatever
but these nights were here and if you're
if you're wanting to establish that as a
family tradition a family Rhythm that's
a good thing it is it's a good thing